17 حكما بالاعدام اصدرها لقضاء الايراني
على عجل في محاوله لقمع وتخويف المتظاهرين
لكنها احكام لن تاتي اكلها على ما يبدو
نفذت العقوبه باربعه منهم فيما ينتظر
الاخرون المصير نفسه شباب
بطموحات عاليه ومهن متنوعه قررت محاكم
النظام الايراني الاقتصاص منهم مستنده الى
مقاطع فيديو غير واضحه واعترافات قصريه
اخذت منهم تحت التعذيب وفقا لمنظمه العفو
الدوليه سرعت المحاكمات خلف ابواب مغلقه
من قبل نظام المحكمه الثوريه الايرانيه لم
يعطى محامهم الفرصه للدفاع عنهم بل ان بين
الحكم وتنفيذه ببعض الحالات اقل من شهر في
دليل على ان هذه المحاكمات يصواريه
ومحسومه مسبقه فهمت محمد زاده سته 20 عاما
بطلوا كما الاجسام اعتقل في الثالث
والعشرين من سبتمبر في العاصمه طهران بعد
مشاركته في احتجاجات واتهم باحراق سله
مهملات واطارات وتدمير قطبان على الطرق
السريعه واعتمددت ادله المحكمه على مقطع
فيديو قال محاميه انه مفبرك انكر المتهم
الذي يعمل في محل مجوهرات صغير في مركز
تجاري التهم الموجهه ضده بل ان اكثر من
100ظف وصاحب متجر وقع على عريضه تضمن
براءته لكن لم يستجب القضاء للمناشدات حتى
الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخونا
[موسيقى]
المصير
الذي اعتقل في اواخر اكتوبر في طهران
والتهمه بمهاجمه احد اعضاء البسيج بالسكين
واشعال النار في دراجه ناريه واتلاف هاتف
نقال وسندت ادله المحكمه الى اللقطات
فيديو منخفضه الجوده لا يظهر فيها سكين
بحسب منظمه العفو الغريب ان عضو البسيج
ورجل الدين الذين قدموا الشكوى سحباها
لمحاوله انقاذ صدرات من الاعدام بالفعل تم
تعليق حكم الاعدام بحقه قبل ساعات فقط من
الموعد المقرر لاعدامه فجرا لكن لازال
وضعه غير المستقبل
وبتوها من متشابهه تقريبا
حكم على محمد بروغاني ومحمد قبادلو سامان
صيدي وحميد قره حسن لو وكذلك ما نتشهر
مهما نواز وحسين محمدي جميعهم ينتظرون
المصير نفسه الاعدام شنقه
[موسيقى]
الشرطي قتل في مكان اخر حسب موقع الشرطه
نفسه اي انه قتل في مدينه الرباط كريم
ولكن نسبه الى ملف ابنه هذا ما ذكره موقع
الشرطه عندما كان الشرطي ملقا على الارض
ركله الناس الا انهم نسبوه الى ملف ابني
حتى يعدموه كما قال الخطيب في يوم تشيع
جثمان القتيل كرمبور بانهم تجمعوا عليه
هنا وقتلوه هنا ما يعني انه قتل خلال
اشتباك وليس نتيجه لدعسه بسياره الجميع
يعلم ذلك لكن تعمدوا ان ينسبوه الى ملف
ابنه ليشنقه هؤلاء يمارسون الظلمه انهم
ظلمه
[تصفيق]
مصير من ذكرنا حتى الان معلق على امل
التراجع عن احكام اعدامهم لكن هذه الفرصه
لم تتح لمحمد مهدي كرمي الذي اعدم في
السابع من يناير اي امس بعد نحو شهرين فقط
من اعتقاله في الكرش التهما كرم بقتل احد
عناصر البسيج خلال احتجاجات في كراج
والسناده المحكمه الى الاعترافات القسريه
التي بثها التلفزيون الحكومي بحسب منظمه
العفو سيد محمد
ايضا في اليوم نفسه اي السابع من يناير
كذلك بعد حوالي شهرين من اعتقاله في اوائل
نوفمبر التهما بالجريمه نفسها التي اتهم
فيها الكرامه قتل عضو في البسيج اثناء
احتجاجات كراج بعد زياره السجن حيث كان
محتجزا قال محاميه علي شريف زاد اردني على
تويتر انه موكله له تعرض لتعذيب شديدا
وضرب بايدي مقيده
عينين مغمضتين ولكن على راسه وسقط فاقدا
للوعي وضرب بقديب حديدي على باطن قدمين
[موسيقى]
سبقهما محسن شكاري الذي اعدم في الثامن من
ديسمبر بعد اقل من ثلاثه اشهر على اعتقاله
كان اول متظاهر يعرف بانه يقتل في اعدام
رسمي وجهت اليه تهمه حرق سله مهملات وقطع
طريق وطعن احد افراد ميليشيا البسيج
وتهديد السلامه العامه تبعه الى المصير
نفسه مجيد رضا
رهنا ورد الذي يعتقل فتاسه عشر من نوفمبر
في مدينه مشهد شمال شرق البلاد وشنق من
رافعه علنا في الثانيه من ديسمبر بعد اقل
من شهر على اعتقاله كان المتظاهر الثاني
المعروف باعدامه رسميه في مقطع فيديو وتم
التقاطه قبل اعدامه وتحققت منه وعائلته
يبدو
رهن ورد معصوب العينين ويده مغطاه
بالجبيره قال لمراسل لا اريدهم ان يبكوا
عند قبر